Leo Messi
is in Miami a true Floridian dude yeah
just popped into Publix normal guy just
a [__] with her family no big deal so
there is a video of him uh walking
around Publix with his family which is
just an amazing Pizza PR it's like
letting everybody in Florida know yo
listen uh he's here he's just like you
he's walking around probably so yeah you
got the tender stuff oh if you got the
tenders then uh no but say the other
part where like the video came out that
like he almost immediately asked for the
car keys from his wife and then just
went back into the car yeah
from what I already took a decent number
of pictures and I was like I'm done he's
like I can't be normal grocery shop who
does this
be around a grocery store the idea it's
probably been his entire life since he
went grocery shopping the kid
was sold
to in football slavery yeah football
slavery yeah two Barcelona lot of
freedom out this weekend I gotta go save
these little child football kids
um he was sold in child football slavery
to Barcelona at 13 years old maybe
younger something like that yeah 11 I
thought maybe so I don't think he's ever
been to a grocery store
when would you go grocery store could it
be for a second
I just want to see what it feels like to
be normal and then immediately he's like
no this sucks give me the car keys I'm
out yeah that's what I think Oh I
thought you were saying it was a PR
stunt where they were like hey go do
normal no he did the PR stunt he was
like all right I'm done we got the
pictures uh I see yeah I'm saying maybe
he was just like yeah let's just take
let's let me just see what this is like
let me see what it's like maybe you
wanted to show and then very quickly he
was like you know what this sucks
yeah yeah I don't know maybe maybe I
don't know but I think it's I think it's
great it's great that he's here
um but there's no way that he's going to
be shopping Arielle said I think he said
this is the biggest moment in American
Sports history or something like that
Ariel helwani it's tweeted something
something that was like very like this
is a massive massive massive deal
on ice
I mean I love messy but there's like a
lot of this I don't know if it's a
hockey thing Market yeah but no the
geopolitical component of the Cold War
bro it's like yeah Great American Sports
Mama yeah I don't know
yeah what would you say what is it
people do say that but I I that's like
um
if you're around at the time
yeah like a newscaster says that because
they're like we got it
is the greatest moment in American
Sports history American eyes I mean
how many people watched Muhammad Ali
beat
um George Foreman yeah that's gotta be
out there I thought it was the Olympics
where the guy
that that very black answer is that yeah
I forgot the name Jesse Owens yeah
white boy oh that's your boy
that was crazy I see okay
but who is it though I still don't know
this is a black panther the biggest
thing in America soccer yeah we don't
need it in history oh it's amazing
American soccer history but what's the
biggest thing in American Sports history
I'm trying to think
and big boxing matches and
oh Joe Lewis taking out Max schmelling
World War II an American takes out the
German in Revenge after the German took
out the American first loss on Joe
Lewis's career I like this he just
spoiled it I like this no Max melling
was a great man he hit Jews during the
war he refused to go to dinner with
Hitler until Hitler made him you'd love
him I like him wait yeah so he beat up a
guy that was helping Jews
[Laughter]
what about what about Jackie Robinson
breaking the color barrier which is such
a funny way it's just like baseball
though
huh
oh George W bush pitching a first pitch
after 9 11. [__] heater down the pipe
yeah just like [__] Al Qaeda yeah yo
who had better you said
no those plans
Al just pointed to the headline Jesse
Owens wins gold in the 36 Olympics
you're talking about that dude that
ain't him you think that was 1936 bruh
the sun yeah they just colorized it now
for us don't say that word anymore bro
come on yeah I do just put all black
history on one guy he was like we have
to end this podcast that's not Jackie
Robinson has Martin Luther King senior
bro come on Michael Jordan